le documentaire et notamment à la fiche
dans les cinémas de tours et de blois au
centre de l'histoire un chêne vieux de
deux cent dix ans dont les racines sont
implantés en plein coeur de la sologne
le réalisateur laurent charbonnier a
décidé de braquer sa caméra sur cet
arbre majestueux durant quatre saisons
l'occasion de découvrir la diversité des
animaux qui l'abritent ou qui vivent à
ses côtés théodore de carros est allé
faire connaissance avec cet arbre est
avec celui qui l'a mise en valeur
regardez
nous voici au pied de l'arbre de noël
c'est ainsi que le surnomme laurent
charbonnier pendant cinq ans ce
réalisateur solognot a fait de ce chêne
l'objet de tout un film actuellement en
salle pendant 1h20 projeté sur grand
écran le patriarche des forêts mais
aussi ses habitants à bout de branche
par exemple un nid d'écureuil à ses
pieds les traces fraîches d'un sanglier
niché sous ses racines des mulots
sylvestre et encore bien d'autres petits
êtres parfois surprenants et à l'eau cet
insecte absolument incroyable et le
balanins moi je le connaissais pas ce
que je voyais des deux langues au sol
des fois avec un trou donnant donc voilà
je savais que c'était un insecte qui
faisait ça mais il n'avait pas vraiment
un film ennemis rencontrés tous tirent
profit de ce cher et surtout de ses
fruits les clans dont ils se délecteront
à l'automne il aura fallu à laurent
charbonnier des centaines d'heures de
rushes et d'affût pour capturer ce monde
invisible
pourtant située à un seul petit
kilomètre de chez lui
en fait la fuite principale était ici
parce que les vents d'ouest sont
dominants évidemment chez nous et
j'étais évidemment un très bon vent
quand les chevreuils arrivé est arrivé
sous reçoit de la gauche va de la droite
et quelquefois même il passé à 4 mètres
cinquante de moi c'était assez étonnant
pour aller nourrir souvent sous le chêne
comme y avait un petit peu plus d'herbe
pour cette petite clairière tu sais dans
ce périmètre que le cinéaste et son
équipe capte plus d'un an et demi de la
vie de l'arbre couinements des mulots
sifflement dg grommellements des
sangliers le réalisateur relève le défi
dans son film pas une seule voix humaine
la parole est aux chaînes et à ses
habitants